[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 Daniela Blandón de nuevo en nuestro
estudio Daniela mea nostalgia hablar de
este tema porque es uno de los lugares
preferidos en mi vida Disney y tiene un
nuevo presidente Sí señor Pues dicen que
el buen hijo Vuelve a casa vamos a
regresar pronto
regresa por dos años para Sorpresa del
mercado pues lo hace menos de un año
después de su retiro él llevaba 15 años
siendo presidente de ejecutivo y salió
por la puerta grande el año pasado
después de realizar varias adquisiciones
clave como por ejemplo Pixar Marvel y
Twenty First Century Fox también
multiplicó por cinco su capitalización
de Mercado va a reemplazar a Bob Chapel
quien asumió el cargo de decir o en
Disney en febrero de 2020 justo cuando
golpeó la pandemia del covid 19 esto
provocó el cierre de todos los parques y
restricciones para Los visitantes en
todo el mundo alguien se había quedado
un año más para facilitar la transición
pero al parecer no dio resultado con su
sucesor está la empresa Danny en una
mala situación real no es una malísima
situación lo que pasa es que la empresa
quiere impulsar el segmento de
transmisión por streaming y aumentar la
confianza de los inversionistas que han
golpeado su acción en un 40% desde
dinero de este año y es que Disney ha
decepcionado este mes cuando mostró
pérdidas crecientes en su unidad de
transmisión que incluye a Disney Plus
que no ha podido despegar ni competirle
a Netflix por ejemplo a Amazon Prime Un
día después del informe sus acciones
tocaron mínimos de 20 años bueno y el
banco interamericano de desarrollo
también estrena presidente también
estrena presidente hablamos del
brasileño y langostin quien es el actual
director del departamento del hemisferio
occidental del fondo monetario
internacional
obtuvo el visto bueno de la asamblea de
gobernadores del bit que está formada
por los ministros de economía de los 48
países que la forman hacer El reemplazo
de Mauricio claver Carolina el primer
estadounidense en dirigir la institución
y nominado en su momento por Donald
Trump había sido destituido después de
haber tenido una relación sentimental
con una subordinada a quien según
investigaciones internas le subió el
sueldo varias veces la importancia del
radica en que es el banco de desarrollo
más grande de América Latina en 2021
conducó más de 23 mil millones de
dólares en la región pero la selección
de golf ha tenido tintes políticos Sí
señor también el ex presidente del Banco
Central de Brasil fue denominado por el
presidente saliente de Brasil Yair
bolsonaro el equipo de Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva lo felicitó a regañadientes a
pesar de que en su momento fue muy
criticado por el partido de los
trabajadores cuando se desempeñaban este
cargo eran golfe dejó el camino a dejó
en el camino a candidatos de Argentina
Trinidad y Tobago y México este último
país lamentó su nombramiento bueno y
empieza el mundial de Qatar y también se
disparan las apuestas en línea como lo
estábamos conversando con nuestro
segundo invitado del día y con más
Romero pues la firma londinense platech
que es uno de los más grandes
proveedores de software de juegos de
azar y del mundo realizó una encuesta en
cinco países de América Latina y
descubrió que en los últimos seis meses
han aumentado drásticamente las apuestas
de cara al Mundial de Qatar en concreto
2500 personas fueron encuestadas Perú es
el país más activo en esta clase de
apuestas con más del 80% de personas que
dijo haber jugado le siguen Colombia con
el 75% chile con el 68 Brasil con el 60
y en todo caso ninguno tiene menos del
50% en Argentina es esta cantidad
también hay que decir que hay riesgos
asociados con esta actividad y en todos
los casos menos de la mitad de los
jugadores fueron advertidos de estos
riesgos
si bien la copa del mundo es un periodo
importante para la captación de clientes
y sobre aprovisionamiento también ofrece
una gran oportunidad para la educación
de los clientes Ese es el momento en el
que los operadores deberían aprovechar
para educar y recordar a los clientes
las herramientas de juego responsable
disponibles como los límites de depósito
los límites de apuesta los tiempos de
espera y la auto exclusión si es
necesario Eso es realmente clave los
clientes deberían encontrar fácilmente
esas herramientas de control en los
sitios de apuestas Y cómo están los
mercados Dani hablemos de los
indicadores económicos bueno tristes
este lunes con excepción de Disney que
en operaciones previas al mercado se
dispara más del 8%. los mercados
bursátiles mundiales si se hunden por la
ansiedad sobre los planes de la reserva
Federal de aumentar más las tasas de
interés Europa perdió durante toda la
mañana porque los inversionistas temen
que estas salsas puedan la economía
mundial a una recesión y en Asia las
pérdidas fueron incluso peores porque
china pues está anunciando más medidas
y esto pues halastrado las bolsas en
esta región Dani como siempre Gracias
por toda la información económica mañana
más economía veremos qué tenemos para
mañana veremos que tenemos para mañana
con que no sorprende el mundo bursá